-Performing "Wet Dream"
from their upcoming
self-titled album,
please welcome Wet Leg!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Beat me up ♪
-♪ Count me in ♪
-♪ 3, 2, 1 ♪
♪ -Let's begin ♪
♪ Here we go ♪
-♪ Here we go ♪
-♪ Here we go, here we go,
here we go, go, go ♪
♪ I was in your wet dream
driving in my car ♪
♪ Saw you at the side
of the road ♪
♪ There's no one else around ♪
♪ You're touching yourself,
touching yourself ♪
♪ Touching your, touching
yourself, touching yourself ♪
♪ You said, "Baby, do you
want to come home with me?"
♪ I got 'Buffalo '66' on DVD" ♪
♪ You said, "Baby, do you
want to come home with me?
♪ I got 'Buffalo '66' on DVD" ♪
♪ Beat me up ♪
-♪ Beat me up ♪
-♪ Count me in ♪
-♪ 3, 2, 1 ♪
♪ -Let's begin ♪
♪ Here we go ♪
-♪ Here we go ♪
-♪ Here we go, here we go,
here we go, go, go ♪
♪ I was in your wet dream
driving in my car ♪
♪ What makes you think
you're good enough ♪
♪ To think about me when
you're touching yourself? ♪
♪ Touching yourself,
touching your ♪
touching yourself ♪
♪ You climb onto the bonnet now,
you're licking the windscreen ♪
♪ I've never seen anything
so obscene ♪
♪ It's enough to make
a girl blush ♪
♪ It's enough, it's enough
to make a girl blush ♪
♪ It's enough, it's enough,
it's enough, it's enough ♪
♪ Beat me up ♪
-♪ Beat me up ♪
-♪ Count me in ♪
-♪ 3, 2, 1 ♪
♪ -Let's begin ♪
♪ Here we go ♪
-♪ Here we go ♪
-♪ Here we go, here we go,
here we go, go, go ♪
♪ Beat me up ♪
-♪ Beat me up ♪
-♪ Count me in ♪
-♪ 3, 2, 1 ♪
♪ -Let's begin ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]